positionnant aujourd'hui merci au
collègues d'être présent dans un plaisir
de vous entendre à l'occasion de notre
mission d'information je vous remercie
de votre venue avec vos collaborateurs
alors bien sûr notre mission sa chemise
vers la fin de ses travaux et il est
important que vous puissiez nous
présenter la vision de l'avenir de la
commune et du maire que telle qu'elle
est défendue par l'État
pour des derniers mois nous avons pu
faire le constat d'une crise d'évocation
ou d'un découragement des mers souvent
lors de nos auditions ou de nos
déplacements les élus ont insisté sur le
divorce entre les responsabilités qui
pèsent sur eux et la faiblesse des
moyens dont ils dispose ou celle de qui
leur est apporté quelle est à cet égard
votre analyse de la situation des
communes et des mers staturant forcé de
l'élu différenciation territoriale
autonomie réglementaire créatribution
conventionnelle de compétences
transférées réinvestissement par l'état
de l'ingénierie territoriale beaucoup de
pistes sont évoqués par les élus et nous
sera précieux que vous nous indiquiez au
cours de l'heure qui vient qu'elle voit
vous paraissent devoir être exploré pour
assurer aux communes et aux maires
l'avenir qu'il mérite je vais laisser de
suite la parole sur un porteur merci
madame la Présidente et Messieurs Madame
la Directrice merci de votre présence
aujourd'hui et dans la droite ligne de
ce que vient de
d'évoquer en propose la présidente moi
finalement j'aurais une question
introductive à vous poser effectivement
nous avons été à la rencontre de
plusieurs territoires nous avons
enchaîné les auditions et il est un
constat qui
ne s'impose pas en tout lieu du
territoire mais pour être assez assez
clair sur une grande partie sur une
majeure partie des territoires que nous
avons rencontrés c'est la difficulté
qu'on les met aujourd'hui à trouver de
la lisibilité et parfois de l'efficience
dans le le lien et le cheminement qui
les mène
au service de l'État et particulièrement
vers
ceux des serviteurs de l'État sur sur
les territoires il y a là un paradoxe
parce qu'on note une volonté de voir
l'état territorial l'être renforcé
singulièrement si j'osais dans les
sous-préfectures qui étaient quand même
un lieu d'écoute c'est donc ma première
question c'est selon vous comment nous
pouvons aujourd'hui retrouver une forme
de fluidité
déficience d'accès facilité entre le
maire les élus municipaux et l'État
territorial illustrer mon propos avec
deux trois exemples pour être très très
concret on l'a vu notamment sur l'accès
aux différentes dotations de l'État
c'est pas un sujet nouveau nous avions
d'ailleurs eu l'occasion d'échanger
dessus des modalités qui diffèrent de la
DETR à la des aujourd'hui au fond vert
pour finalement
avoir accès à des dotations qui sont
celles de l'État et qu'on aurait
peut-être
intérêt parfois à regrouper notamment
dans
l'accès pour qu'il soit facilité pour
les élus locaux c'est aussi vrai sur la
question de l'ingénierie où on sent bien
et nous l'avons dit au directeur de la
NCT que
l'accès à l'ingénierie et notamment
l'ingénierie de l'État reste encore
quelque chose de complexe notamment pour
celle des communes qui ne font pas
partie de la politique d'appel à projet
ou de la labellisation petite ville de
demain action coeur de ville et qui se
trouve parfois démuni particulièrement
dans des départements où il n'y a pas
d'ingénierie donc comment on peut
peut-être rendre tout ça un peu plus
lisible et plus accessible pour pour les
différents maires des différents
territoires de France
merci beaucoup de modifier et pour cette
première question peut-être je
commencerai par vous dire en préalable
que c'est vrai que cette audition
s'inscrit dans un contexte de triple
crise et que qui appelle quand même
c'est vrai une vraie réflexion à mener
par les services de l'État vous l'avez
dit en introduction crise d'évocation
c'est un phénomène difficile à mesurer
et qui aujourd'hui mesurait par sondage
le dernier sondage que nous nous avons
identifié d'adoctobre 2022 et indiquait
que 55% des maires ne souhaitaient pas
se représenter lors de la prochaine
mandature et même s'il s'agit d'un
sondage avec beaucoup de précautions
méthodologiques à avoir c'est quand même
un chiffre qui interroge évidemment
crise des démissions vous l'avez bien
sûr également cité avec des chiffres
difficiles à interpréter puisque pour
une partie ça lui semblait démission des
mers ils sont peut-être en légère baisse
par rapport rapport à la même date à
mi-mandat du mandat précédent mais pour
les conseillers municipaux ils sont en
légère hausse et en toute état de cause
des chiffres quand même qui restent
élevés en valeur absolue et donc qui
pose question et enfin crise plus
générale de violent envers les élus
qu'on voit très bien dans le contexte
actuel donc peut-être cette
effectivement triple crise qui qui
interroge et qui vient aussi dans un
contexte où il y a eu beaucoup de
réformes institutionnelles ces dernières
années et qui ont aussi pu dérouter et
notamment la l'intercommunalité
l'accroissement de sa taille
concomitante à un renforcement
d'intégration des compétences et ça on
voit aussi beaucoup nous dans nos
retours que il y a encore un certain
nombre d'interrogations sur le
fonctionnement des intercommunalités
aujourd'hui qui ont été aggravés avec la
crise covid qui a parfois peut-être pas
permis à toutes les nouvelles équipes
municipales de d'élaborer des bonnes
solutions de gouvernance commun et donc
peut-être c'est aussi un contexte très
particulier qui génère ce sentiment
d'une voilà d'une peut-être un sujet sur
les vocations et puis une question
institutionnelle qui reste qui reste
pendant et évidemment on se demande
comment les services de l'État peuvent
réagir pour accompagner les élus dans ce
contexte il y a beaucoup d'aspects mais
je réponds à votre question sur
l'ingénierie parce que évidemment sur
les autres sujets que je viens d'aborder
il y aura aussi beaucoup à dire mais sur
les sur l'ingénierie tout d'abord c'est
vrai que les services de l'État ont
inversé la tendance de ces dernières
années en renforçant le niveau
départemental quand je dis ces dernières
années au sens très très large en
remontant sur une vingtaine d'années de
des crus de des effectifs de l'État
départemental qui est voilà on constate
absolument partager donc sur cette
tendance cette inversée avec une
stabilisation puis même maintenant une
hausse des effectifs et une hausse qui
est qui est prévue dans la Loch me qui a
été votée par au Parlement et quand
renforcement des préfectures de
départements et des sous-préfectures
donc vraiment au plus près du terrain se
renforcement des services de l'État le
deuxième axe qui a été
qui a été décidé et ces dernières années
c'est la création de la NCT donc une
nouvelle agence qui est dédiée à
l'ingénierie au profit des collectivités
et qui a déjà donc accompagné plus de
1500 projets en accompagnement sur
mesure mais qui a aussi mis sur le
terrain plus de 2200 chefs de projet
dans les collectivités donc ce sont les
chefs de projets que vous évoquez dans
les dispositifs petite ville de demain
action cœur de ville territoire
d'industrie donc toutes ces communes qui
ont été accompagnées par un chef de
projet co-financé par l'État et ça a
quand même remis plus de deux 2200
effectifs sur les territoires pour aider
les collectivités à développer leurs
projets de territoire alors maintenant
effectivement
comment aller encore plus loin alors il
y a des sujets qui la NCT et que le
Sénat a également traité dans son
rapport sur la NCT c'est être la porte
d'entrée de l'ingénierie être vraiment
un nouveau un guichet unique avec une
plus grande déconcentration visibilité
pour les élus et par la NCT ayant été
encore parfois invisibilisés par le fait
que le l'État est le préfet et sont
délégué territorial et donc le préfet a
sa double casquette déléguée
territoriale de l'anct et évidemment
préfet représentant de l'État dans le
département il a pas toujours quand il
active l'un ou l'autre des dispositifs
communiqués sur le fait qu'il l'activait
au nom de la NCT donc il y avait un
sujet peut-être aussi de visibilité de
des services que pouvait rendre cet
agence au niveau local mais il y a aussi
après un sujet de coordination de toutes
les ingéniers publiques existantes sur
un territoire y compris d'ailleurs celle
des collectivités donc des départements
qui ont fait beaucoup des
intercommunalités donc
là nous on pense que le les comités
locaux de la cohésion des territoires
peuvent être un bon outil qu'il faut
aujourd'hui maintenant les renforcer que
les acteurs sont présents puisque les
collectivités sont représentées tous les
acteurs de l'ingénierie sur un
territoire mais qu'il faut leur donner
un véritable rôle et demander au préfet
de les réunir de les animer et d'en
faire le lieu de la discussion du
partage des ingéniers existantes et
aussi de la codécision de quelle est la
bonne ingénierie à mobiliser sur les
projets pour éviter aussi le reproche
car parfois pu être faite à la NCT d'une
substitution
d'une ingénierie de l'État à une
ingénierie locale qui était déjà
existante et ça aussi un écueil qu'il
faut éviter pour pas affaiblir des
structures locales qui fonctionnent bien
et vraiment apporter une plus-value là
où il y avait des des manques
d'ingénierie mais pas venir évidemment
se substituer donc ça c'est un premier
axe de renforcement le deuxième axe de
renforcement de l'action de l'État et de
simplification vous l'avez cité c'est
sur les dotations c'est à dire
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui avec la
création du fond vert il y a trois
dotations majeur qui viennent soutenir
les projets locaux donc on peut que s'en
réjouir d'avoir 4 milliards d'euros qui
viennent alimenter les les projets des
communes toutefois ces trois dotations
elles ont aujourd'hui des règles
d'emploi différentes des calendriers
d'instructions qui peuvent être
différents et des priorités différentes
alors les priorités différentes tant
mieux parce que sinon ça veut dire
qu'elle se réfusionnée donc probablement
un jour raboté mais donc c'est logique
qu'elles aient des priorités différentes
mais il faut sans doute simplifier les
procédures les rapprocher harmoniser les
calendriers donc nous on est tout à fait
enclin à prendre toute notre part à ce
travail là et à se rapprocher de des
administrations qui gèrent le fond vert
pour pouvoir
harmoniser toutes ces procédures et
aller vers là encore à terme un
formulaire quasiment unique enfin pour
que l'élu pour que ce soit transparent
en pote en fait pour lui et internaliser
cette contrainte alors qui peut
s'expliquer par le fait que ce sont des
mécanismes nouveaux qui ont été créés
quand même très rapidement avec des
sommes très importantes et à effectifs
constants donc c'est aussi voilà je veux
dire j'ai aussi saluer le fait que les
services de l'État arrive à répartir 4
milliards d'euros sans ETP
supplémentaire sur cette mission dans
des délais très courts en instruant un
nombre de dossiers considérable donc ce
sont des mécanismes qui marchent
extrêmement bien aujourd'hui qui
rencontre un grand succès et qui seront
dans les autorisations d'engagement
seront intégralement consommés en 2023
peut-être dernière piste de de
proposition de de réforme qui est portée
par la ministre Dominique Faure vous
savez quel soutient l'idée de développer
l'ingénierie aussi dans les services de
l'État au profit des collectivités
locales le choix là qui a été fait
jusqu'à présent ça a été de renforcer
directement les collectivités locales
par la mise à disposition de chef de
projet l'idée aussi de pouvoir avoir une
ingénierie dans les préfectures qui
soient à même d'accompagner les projets
des collectivités mais on renforçant
aussi les services de l'État sur ces
sujets notamment en renforçant les
sous-préfet voilà peut-être je
m'arrêterai là pour votre première
question
merci en tout cas de ces premiers
éléments de réponse je vais peut-être
aller un peu plus loin que mon propos
introductif pour vous donner
finalement les exemples de
dysfonctionnement qu'on a rencontré sur
les territoires vous dites c'est bien
d'avoir une spécificité des fonds
je vais vous poser la même question que
j'ai posé au démat au directeur de la
NCT je vous mets au défi de me trouver
un seul des départements de France dans
lequel préfet et sous-préfet n'ont pas
dû substituer une enveloppe à une autre
pour financer un projet on devait
fléchir sur de la dotr on a finalement
atterri sur de la desciles et
aujourd'hui on vous laisse à imaginer
qu'on peut aller sur le fond vert quel
intérêt y a-t-il encore à maintenir
trois enveloppes qui relèvent de trois
dispositifs différents dans des
territoires où les maires nous dit on
vous en supplie arrêtez de nous rendre
la vie plus compliquée chaque jour parce
que faire un dossier et regarder les
projets qui ont été ligibles au fond
vert trouvez-moi des petites communes
qui ont eu accès aux fonds verts
deuxième défi pourquoi
continuer si ce n'est et ce qui est
d'ailleurs assez symptomatique c'est que
vous nous dites si on enlève cette
spécificité en rabote mais comment on
peut imaginer que parce qu'on
simplifierait on serait amené à raboter
je veux dire c'est inaudible pardon de
le dire comme ça et c'est là je pointe
pas du tout du doigt votre propos parce
que c'est le propos qu'on nous tient
depuis le texte de la loi 3DS nous
avions essayé
essayez de juste faire en sorte sans
fusionner des Etats des cils que le
préfet département qui lui instruit les
dossiers de la décile puisse
sous autorisation du préfet de région
notifié
je veux dire aujourd'hui on en est là
quand les sénateurs que nous sommes en
explications je peux vous assurer qu'on
n'est pas quand même accueilli de la
meilleure des façons considérant que le
législateur peut pas mettre bon ordre là
dedans deuxième sujet
l'ingénierie d'État mais pourquoi on
multiplie les canaux pourquoi
aujourd'hui on a moi je me souviens du
débat que nous avons eu dans l'hémicycle
il y a quelques années sur la création
de la NCT où tous les ministres le corps
nu gourou qui se sont succédés nous ont
dit on veut un outil agile et qui ne
soit pas quelque chose une strate ou une
agence de plus mais quelque chose qui
met du lien
aujourd'hui pardon de le dire et à
chaque fois qu'on essaie de prêcher pour
un rapprochement
anctéréma Adem sans parler là pour le
coup de fusion on voit bien la
complexité que cela revêt enfin dernier
point les législateurs que nous sommes
avons essayé de faire rutile en matière
de simplification et de coordination de
l'action de l'État sur les territoires
dans le texte 3DS pour se faire on a
fait du préfet de département le délégué
départemental notamment de l'Office
français de la biodiversité le délégué
départemental de la NCT je me tourne
vers les collègues qui nous ont
accompagnés à commencer par la
présidente dans certains départements un
exemple les Vosges les Vosges pour faire
fonctionner la NCT on a confié ça aux
sous préfet de Neufchâteau sous préfet
de Neufchâteau ça faisait 6 mois qu'il
était pas il y avait plus de sous préfet
à Neufchâteau un préfet de région d'un
autre d'une autre région importante 4
départements nous dit chez nous la NCT
c'est bien mais finalement pour les élus
c'est pas identifié c'est pas je veux
dire c'est pas lég ordinateur qui le dis
c'est la même d'une partie des services
de l'État et comprenez bien que pour
nous à la limite c'est pas un problème
s'il y a des etr des cils fond vert fond
rouge faut c'est pas le sujet le sujet
c'est qu'on a une perte en ligne
déficience qui génère pardon de le dire
parce que c'est pas nous qui le disons
c'est les mères que nous avons
additionné rencontrés une forme de
découragement parce que tout ceci pour
quelqu'un qui doit conjuguer avec une
activité professionnelle d'autres
engagements qui émèrent d'une commune de
sang 200-300 500 habitants un
découragement parce que finalement il a
le sentiment que tout ça n'a de raison
que de faire en sorte qu'on génère des
grands regroupements des communes
toujours plus grandes dans des
intercommunalités qui sont elles-mêmes
plus grandes dans des ensembles plus
grands et là je le dis on a bien sûr des
raisons qui sont multifactorielles au
découragement des mers mais celle-ci il
ne faut pas la méconnaître et l'ignorer
d'autant plus qu'on arrive clairement
plus nous même alors qu'on a fait des
efforts pour légiférer et rendre tout ce
schéma un peu plus simple visible tout
simplement à l'expliquer donc vraiment
j'appelle votre attention sur ce sujet
parce que quand souvent on interpelle
les ministres y compris même les propos
de la première ministre qui dit mais on
met toujours plus d'argent sur les
territoires mais nous on est même pas
demandé plus d'argent on est là à
demander que l'organisation de l'État
sur les territoires génèrent plus
d'Efficient vous voyez on est enfin on
est on est quand même pas dans quelque
chose qui est démentiel quoi et on a
vraiment le sentiment que on se parle de
part et d'autre mais sans se comprendre
et ça pour nous c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui génère une une frustration
merci oui on va enchaîner les questions
avec Catherine berletti
de la Moselle 725 communes alors je peux
vous garantir que quand on a annoncé un
fond vert tout le monde était très
heureux de savoir qu'on avait une
enveloppe supplémentaire mais quand on a
vu la façon dont ça a été organisé et ça
a été la panique générale à la fois du
côté des mers mais également à côté des
administrations la Sous-Préfecture de la
préfecture ça a été une usine à gaz très
sincèrement les mères avaient rempli
leur dossier au moment de la dutr on
leur a dit dans mes transférés parce que
vous allez avoir des fonds
supplémentaires en fond vert ça a pris
un temps fou on nous a dit une heure
pour remplir le dossier il fallait trois
heures sinon plus que et encore il
fallait quelqu'un pour vous aider ce qui
fait que les sous préfectures ont joué
le jeu effectivement on les appelait il
vous aider à remplir vous imaginez le
travail supplémentaire et enfin
aujourd'hui on leur dit ah bah non notre
enveloppe elle est consommée on a plus
rien à vous donner donc des mairies qui
auraient pu avoir une dutr des communes
qui aurait pu avoir une dutr aujourd'hui
se retrouve avec zéro ni l'un ni l'autre
bon donc ce fond vert ça a été une
catastrophe alors on est très heureux
d'avoir ces moyens mais comme le disait
tout à l'heure Mathieu il faut que ça
soit une seule sur une seule porte
d'entrée et effectivement vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure peut-être un seul
dossier aujourd'hui de toute façon les
dossiers sont traités par les sous-prés
et ensuite ils sont envoyés vers le
préfet ouvre vers la préfète vers le
préfet de département vers la préfète de
région pour l'adhésive qui vont juste
accepter ou refuser je veux dire c'est
du temps perdu à un moment donné on fait
un seul dossier et point final et à la
limite ce fond vert on aurait pu le
mettre sur la des îles ça simplifié la
vie de tout le monde et notamment aussi
de toute l'administration en préfecture
je vous assure moi j'ai vu des
administrateurs qui qui étaient au bord
de la dépression et certains même
étaient en dépression donc je veux dire
un moment donné soyons raisonnable on
met des enveloppes facilitons la vie des
mères parce que c'est vraiment un des
premiers motifs de démission aujourd'hui
c'est la lourdeur de la
demande de demande de subventions et là
je soyez vraiment attentif à ce point-là
parce que c'est un des premiers moi
quand je vis avoir les mers c'est la
première chose qu'on me dit je sais pas
où chercher d'avoir les fonds et donc
pour cela j'ai essayé de les aider au
maximum et de c'est trop compliqué
on a quand même 90% des communes en
grandes est qui ont moins de 2000
habitants ça veut dire des mers qui ont
forcément un métier à côté ou qui n'ont
pas de secrétaire toute la semaine
[Musique]
je me suis Jean-Marc voyez ou à Nation
oui merci
je vous ai merci pour votre présentation
je vous ai trouvé très optimiste dans
les présents de la présentation vous
avez mais vous avez raison vous faites
optimiste
concernant les la NCT vous savez les les
mers dans les départements
se tournent bien souvent vers
l'ingénierie départementale ils vont au
plus près et on a beaucoup de
départements aujourd'hui qui ont qui ont
mis en place un service d'ingénierie
chez nous dans le département du
Puy-de-Dôme je ne suis pas présenté
c'est l'agence des partenaires
d'ingénierie territorial qui travaille
directement avec les communes les
communes payent une petite causalisation
annuelle mais qui est très intéressante
parce qu'il y a un service qui est rendu
par le département et ce service il est
venu en complément d'une désaffection de
des services de l'État un moment donné
qui n'ont plus qui n'ont plus existé
il a fallu il a fallu payer
je reviendrai pas sur ce qu'a dit le
rapporteur tout à l'heure sur
l'Office
l'ofb ni sur la DETR parce que bon en
tant que parlementaire on est délégué
président au président de la commission
DETR mais on s'aperçoit que finalement
mise à part un avis ou une suggestion
qu'on peut donner aux sous-préfet je
veux dire notre notre rôle efficace
s'arrête là et je regrette beaucoup je
l'ai déjà dit à plusieurs auditions que
la fameuse réserve parlementaire qui
existait auparavant soit devenu le fdba
sur lequel là on plus on a aucune prise
ça je pense avec quelque chose à mon
avis qu'il faudra certainement modifier
un moment donné
où effectivement là aussi on est
simplement
on analyse tout simplement les décisions
qui sont prises par le représentant de
l'État qui soit sous préfet ou le seul
préfet concernant la det
il y a une chose qui va qui est
alors c'est vrai qu'on manque il y a une
manque de crédit pour satisfaire tous
les demandes de projets des communes
mais il y a aussi il faut que les élus
prennent pas de responsabilité quelque
part parce que moi je m'aperçois que
cette année par exemple on renvoie des
crédits à l'état qui n'ont pas été
utilisés parce que où les communes n'ont
pas fait leur dossier ou elle ne elles
ont eu du retard etc ne l'ont pas
signalé et donc on renvoie des crédits
qui n'ont pas été utilisés alors qu'il y
a des communes qui attendent donc ça
fait partie des choses aussi peut-être
qu'il faudrait essayer de de faire en
sorte et danger mais moi je crois qu'il
y a deux choses il y a deux sortes de
mer depuis les dernières élections il y
a ceux qui avaient une expérience qui
avait un vécu qui savait comment ça
fonctionnait déjà donc le maire est lu
bon il est il est dans le
je dirais pas dans le quotidien mais il
connaît il connaît son sujet et puis il
y a le maire nouveau qui arrive et c'est
cela on s'aperçoit que bien souvent se
retrouve pris dans un système de ce que
disait à partir tout à l'heure d'un
système de contraintes dans un système
de ou une pas eu à mon avis connaissance
ou conscience des difficultés sur
lesquelles ils allaient se trouver et
c'est là je crois où il faut vraiment
qu'il y ait un accompagnement qui soit
fait par rapport à ses maires qui sont
nouveaux que ce soit en termes de
formation d'information de
d'accompagnement et vous parliez tout à
l'heure qu'il y avait 2200 effectifs qui
avaient été dépliés je me demande où ils
sont je vous dis franchement que je me
demande vraiment où ils sont et c'est là
je crois qu'il faudrait vraiment qu'il y
ait un soutien un accompagnement pour
ses mères pour qu'il se sentent soutenu
au moment donné par l'État
merci en tout cas Madame la Directrice
de nous avoir exposé votre point de vue
effectivement nous notre retour du
terrain est bien différent en fait donc
je partage les propos qui ont été
développés jusque là
il y a un point très très important qui
a été soulevé par mon collègue là c'est
celui de la réserve parlementaire parce
que quelque part on s'y retrouve pas il
y avait normalement un ruissellement
vers la DETR et sous une autre forme et
en bref on le sait et on le dit l'État
est impécunieux mais en attendant les
communes et les mers ont besoin
d'établir leur budget lorsqu'ils font
des projets
évidemment avec l'aide de l'État le
souci c'est que ils sont sûrs des aides
des collectivités départements et
régions quand ça s'y prête mais très
très souvent ils étaient déconvenues
très importantes sur les aides de l'État
et si je vous dis ça c'est que ça
appelle aussi une autre remarque sur
notamment la DRAC on a de plus plus en
plus de difficultés à obtenir le
paiement
de subventions de la drague qui ont été
notifiés et quand les mers on les
entreprises qui frappent à leur porte
tous les jours parce que les travaux ont
été effectués et qui a des des factures
de l'ordre de 120 000 130 000 euros
quelque part quelquefois c'est vraiment
impossible donc il y a ce sujet de la
DETR de la décile bien sûr des
notifications du fond vert qui reste une
nébuleuse je voudrais aussi dire que les
mères ont le sentiment que dans les
opérations cœur de ville et petite ville
de demain l'État leur a vendu du rêve
c'est à dire que on fantasme sur l'idée
que pourrait devenir notre centre-ville
centre-ville mais au final qui paye ce
n'est évidemment pas l'état qui met à
disposition une forme d'ingénierie sous
forme de de d'études de réunion pour
pour quelque part
optimiser le projet et déboucher sur des
travaux qui pourraient être effectués
mais au final ce sont aux communes au
département et au régions d'assumer les
travaux donc dans tout cela voilà on
aura beau nous dire 2200 effectifs
supplémentaires des politiques très très
volontaristes au final ça devient
extrêmement difficile de les réaliser
donc pour tout ça je pense qu'il faut
être très pragmatique
on se réunit en début d'année pour
discuter des lignes qui vont être
subventionnées par la DETR on a des
fourchettes aujourd'hui on est plus
précis non plus et pour les mères c'est
de plus en plus difficile
d'établir des projets et se lancer je
vous assure il y a effectivement deux
catégories de mer mais celles de ceux
qui étaient déjà élus auparavant nous
disent que les choses ne se vont pas en
s'améliorant bien au contraire et
dernier petit truc la suppression du
corps préfectoral au mois de janvier
2023 et les conséquences j'aimerais bien
vous entendre tout de même sur ces
conséquences qui sont inévitables et qui
seront perçus par les territoires quand
les préfets partiront et que ce seront
d'autres venus d'autres ministères qui
vont prendre la place peut-être que ça
peut être je comprends le sens voilà
mais en attendant je vous assure que si
la situation était optimale je n'ai
aucune inquiétude or ça n'est pas tout à
fait le cas
[Musique]
merci
mon propos ira dans le même sens de ce
de mes collègues
on a pour partir et l'État aussi
victimes une concordance des temps avec
le renouvellement des conseils
municipaux qui ont amené un certain
nombre de nouveaux élus
en situation
les nouvelles intercommunalités vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure c'est un
vrai sujet où un certain nombre d'élus
n'ont pas retrouvé leur place et
d'autres ne l'ont jamais trouvé
avec un renforcement de la compétence
intercommunale qui dilue la compétence
communale les larron difficilement
compréhensible y compris pour certains
maires eux-mêmes
les nouveaux dispositifs que mis en
oeuvre qu'on a évoqué et puis par dessus
tout ça la période du covid qui a coupé
les relations isolées les élus et qui
les a beaucoup perturbé donc toutes ces
difficultés
sont passés pour certaines encore
effectives
et on va parvenir en arrière donc la
solution aujourd'hui c'est la
simplification
de ce point de vue sur les dotations de
l'État qu'on a évoqué de terre des cils
font verts il y a deux solutions
soit elles deviennent fongibles
soit il y a une différenciation plus
claire que ce qui existe aujourd'hui
faute de quoi on assiste à tout ce qui a
été mentionné et que moi je connais
aussi dans mon département
du bricolage des élus qui ne savent pas
à quelle dotation ils sont éligibles un
sous-préfet qui explique au maire bah
écoutez si vous n'avez pas de DETR c'est
pas grave on va essayer de vous arranger
le coup avec de la lessive ou avec du
fond vert et au final plus personne ne
sait à quoi ça sert donc il y a un
besoin de clarification sur sur ce point
de la même façon qu'il y a un besoin de
clarification sur
l'ingénierie un vous l'avez évoqué
espérons que ça se mette en place
rapidement il faut que les services de
l'État en proximité les sous-préfectures
puissent être renforcés moi j'ai vu une
des plus grosses sous-préfectures de
France à Dieppe se vider de ses
effectifs avec une incapacité totale de
répondre aux sollicitations de près de
270 communes
donc là il faut que le maire bon il
appelle le sous-préfet mais le
sous-préfet n'est pas omniscient et
omniprésent
avoir quelqu'un au bout du fil pour être
renseigné sur comment il doit s'y
prendre de la même façon on a besoin de
simplifier les relations et de clarifier
les relations entre la NCT les agences
de l'État mais aussi avec les agences
territoriales moi dans mon département
lorsque j'étais président de département
j'ai mis en place une agence
départementale de d'ingénierie sous
forme d'un syndicat mixte ça
fonctionnait bien c'était arrive les
gens ne savent plus accuser et le
département lui-même a des difficultés
pour savoir s'il doit maintenir ou pas
son dispositif dans l'état actuel les
choses il le maintient mais demain
est-ce que ça sera nécessaire ou pas
enfin sur
les les
dotation moi j'appelle votre attention
sur la multiplication des appels à
projets
qui rendent les élus un peu fou d'abord
un si vous êtes dans une commune moyenne
ou importante vous avez à la fois les
moyens d'ingénierie propres qui vous
permettent de déceler l'appel à projet
parce que déjà faut savoir qu'il existe
ensuite éventuellement de répondre à au
sollicitations pour pouvoir en
bénéficier mais tout ça c'est quand même
de la mise en concurrence entre les
territoires
et ça devient problématique
dans nos territoires
ceux qui n'en n'ont pas les moyens
passent à côté et de la même façon
je crois qu'il est nécessaire d'attirer
votre attention sur le désarroi des mers
des petites communes qui eux n'ont ni
besoin de gros moyens ni besoin d'appels
à projet ils ont simplement besoin d'une
petite subvention pour renouveler le
tracteur qui est tombé en panne changer
les fenêtres de l'école ou voilà trouver
des subventions de l'ordre de 3000 5000
et pas beaucoup plus ce qui leur permet
de boucler leur budget qui sont déjà
extrêmement contraints et donc ceci
aujourd'hui a quasiment disparu et c'est
une vraie difficulté et ça explique
aussi qu'un certain nombre de maires se
disent moi je ne peux plus rien faire
donc si je ne peux plus rien faire à
quoi bon continuer
pour terminer Cécile que Kerman oui
merci
je dois certainement un défaut parmi
tous mes collègues c'est que en fait je
suis la plus ancienne en fonction et
donc inévitablement cette question
aujourd'hui
de l'engagement des mers elle se pose
avec acuité comme jamais dans d'autres
périodes amis mandat où l'on a toujours
connu plus ou moins effectivement à
mi-mandat municipal des élus qui
s'interrogent sur la capacité à repartir
ou pas
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas simplement une
question de ressenti nous avons d'ores
et déjà amis mandat un certain nombre de
démission alors vous l'évoquiez
certainement pour des raisons diverses
mais qui en tout cas doivent toutes et
quelles qu'on soit la raison nous
inquiéter parce que il me semble aussi
que nous avons pour le coup tous en
commun la volonté d'affirmer donc de
tout mettre en œuvre
pour le fait que
la République ne fonctionne pas sans les
maires et sont les élus locaux
et donc ce n'est pas qu'un petit sujet
je voilà et face à cette situation il y
a deux écueils
des propos
auxquels vous ont qualifié de propos
très optimistes je pense que première
accueil ce serait hyper optimiste le
deuxième écueil serait très certainement
l'hyper pessimisme et de se dire qu'il
n'y aurait rien à faire et que nous
soyons face à une fatalité qui pourrait
nous dévorer
d'incapacité à agir d'ailleurs donc il
serait dangereux
je crois qu'il y a aussi et très
certainement dans l'explication de cette
période le fait que les maires
finalement sont à l'image des Françaises
et des françaises qui est plutôt
rassurant et que donc la vocation de
l'engagement que l'on retrouve dans le
monde associatif dans l'ensemble de la
fonction publique en général
était aussi présente chez la mère
je mets ça au préalable parce que bien
évidemment les propos y compris les
propositions et les remarques que font
mes collègues je crois qu'il faut les
inscrire dans cette dimension là
on peut penser que c'est bien ou pas
bien mais oui aujourd'hui face à cette
crise de l'engagement il faut donc
sécuriser déjà l'engagement qui existent
et donner à d'autres demain l'envie de
s'engager
et que
la spécificité des fonds
peut-être que d'un point de vue Traité
théorique c'est justifiable et des
fondables mais aujourd'hui c'est une
difficulté énorme
peut-être
que
la présence d'une ingénierie sous
différentes formes qu'elles soient
parfois de la NCT parfois de ce qui
reste dans les préfectures et les
sous-préfectures et je vous prends au
mot dans ce que ce sera demain avec le
réarmement de l'État dans les
territoires
il n'en demeure pas moins qu'aujourd'hui
il y a une forme d'illisibilité qui
décourage et qui décourage des nouveaux
maires et qui découragent les anciens
maires le pire étant bien évidemment les
anciens parce qu'il compare à ce qui
existait avant et que vous n'avez pas
chez les nouveaux maires le regret de
l'ancienne D2 quand vous l'avez bien
évidemment chez les anciens et donc je
crois qu'il faut en tout cas y faire
attention et que finalement cela invite
à repenser réellement
le rôle de l'État dans sa capacité à se
déconcentrer pour sécuriser cette
décentralisation qui qui est importante
moi il me semble que donc il y a besoin
d'une plus forte présence en nombre une
plus forte présence en qualité quand je
dis ça ça ne peut pas dire que les
agents de l'État aujourd'hui présent
serait des incapable attention mais dans
cette capacité à être au quotidien et
pas simplement sur un droit de tirage en
capacité
d'accompagner ces élus qui ne passeront
plus leur week-end entier à faire des
choses qu'il faisait avant et que donc
oui l'ingénierie aujourd'hui elle
devient nécessaire et que l'on sait
aussi que à l'inverse dans un certain
nombre de communes il n'y a pas de
nécessité à avoir un employé communal
qui qui maîtrise cette ingénierie et
donc je crois qu'on est là sur sur un
équilibre très juste puis je terminerai
sans aucune polémique nous nous
livrerons pas les débats ici mais si je
pense que parfois il faut savoir revenir
en arrière
on l'a fait très légèrement avec
engagement et proximité on s'attaquant
aux fameux irritants de la loi neutre
je crois que oui effectivement ces lois
ont fortement fragilisé pour diverses
raisons d'ailleurs
la place des communes en tout cas elles
ont amené un certain nombre d'élus à
s'interroger
sur l'efficacité et l'utilité de leur
engagement et en fait c'est dur de
s'engager mais quand on pense que de
toutes les façons ce que l'on va faire
ne sert pas ou est devenu impossible
parce que l'intercommunalité
décide à la place ou parce que l'État
n'est plus là en amont pour nous aider à
mettre en œuvre ce qu'attendre la
population mais pour nous dire que ce
que l'on a construit n'est pas possible
et bien effectivement là nous
aggraverons et collectivement la crise
de l'engagement demain et ça je crois
que c'est une inquiétude en tout cas que
nous devons avoir et sur laquelle nous
devons continuer de travailler très
fortement et donc ça passe oui par des
moyens financiers ça passe par des
moyens humains ça passe aussi par la
capacité à redonner du pouvoir non pas
pour renforcer
des barons locaux mais à redonner du
pouvoir parce que le pouvoir le pouvoir
de faire c'est le pouvoir de répondre
aux attentes d'une population fragilisée
aujourd'hui c'est le pouvoir de fédérer
des équipes sur des projets parce qu'il
y a cette satisfaction du projet réalisé
et bien mené et c'est le pouvoir de
pouvoir d'être en capacité d'expliquer
un certain nombre de décisions après
elles plaisent elles ne plaisent pas
elles sont contestables mais ça c'est ça
c'est la démocratie mais une fois tant
qu'on peut on est il y a pas de souci
mais en tout cas de pouvoir faire et ça
et je le dis parce que moi j'ai beaucoup
y compris des luttes je frappais en
quelques années qui quasiment n'ont plus
accès à un certain nombre d'informations
de grandes entreprises de notamment en
matière de téléphonie par exemple de
grandes administrations
matières de transport ferroviaire ou
avant un maire quel que soit la taille
de sa commune il faisait un courrier il
appelait il avait des réponses
aujourd'hui il n'en a pas et comme ils
me disent tous mais la question n'est
pas qu'on me dise que c'est possible ou
pas possible
mais quand il y a plus de téléphone on
ne leur répond plus alors pourra me dire
c'est très bien en tant que sénateur on
fait un courrier derrière nous on nous
répond on transmet en mer le maire pense
qu'on est des vedettes alors qu'on a
juste fait un courrier voilà j'ai pas de
souci mais je pense que quand même cela
montre un certain dysfonctionnement et
renforce en tout cas ce sentiment
d'impuissance qui n'est pas sain
merci
je rebondis sur ce que vient de dire
Cécile Kerman sur les effectifs je pense
qu'on a vu sa menuiser au fur et à
mesure les effectifs de l'État local
l'état départemental et c'est
aujourd'hui qu'on en mesure un peu les
effets
des maths l'autre jour nous disait on a
perdu 4700 équivalentes en plein de 2010
à 2020 sur l'état local et petit à petit
bien entendu les talocal a dû se
recentrer sur le règlementaire et non
plus sur l'accompagnement et c'est ce
qu'on entend aujourd'hui de des mères
qui nous disent qu'ils sont plus
accompagnés et conseillés comme il était
auparavant alors bien sûr cette perte
d'effectif aussi elle occasionne une
reconcentration des services
automatiquement avec bien sûr des
responsabilités qui sont
recherchées plus haut moins pour cela je
pense qu'il faut retrouver bien sûr des
effectifs sur les territoires mais aussi
de la souplesse et de l'agilité
notamment refaire confiance au préfet je
donne toujours j'ai donné l'autre jour
l'exemple j'étais en commission
départementale d'attribution du fond de
la vie associative et de la jeunesse
numéro 2 donc l'enveloppe départementale
pour donner 200 euros à une association
pour un petit festival cette enveloppe
est remonte au préfet de région qui doit
donner lui son accord après que l'État
le département préfet du département est
fait la répartition enfin je trouve que
ça c'est un peu c'est un peu dommage de
pas à retrouver un peu de de souplesse
et d'agilité au niveau des préfets et
des sous-préfectures le dernier point
que que je donnerai aussi c'est la
cohérence avec les autres financeurs
publics on a perdu aussi ce lien que les
financeurs les co-financeurs avaient sur
les territoires il faut retrouver aussi
cette cette cohésion avec les autres
financeurs que sont le département ou la
région
voir les forts européens mais ça aussi
derrière
chacun qui a repris un peu ses billes et
qui
qui a son petit prix carré et on arrive
à des choses localement ou moi je suis
je suis conseillère départementale j'ai
une enveloppe confiée par le Conseil
départemental pour l'action locale ça
s'appelle le fond d'aménagement rural je
le distribue à l'échelle mon canton et
avant de le distribuer je vais voir le
sous-préfet pour savoir lui ce qu'il a
mis en doter pour pas qu'on ait des
surfinancement un certain moment qui
tomberaient automatiquement quand on
examinerait les dossiers donc voilà on
s'organise comme ça mais c'est pas
institutionnalisé et je pense que un
guichet aussi des co-financeurs serait
utile et le dernier point que je
donnerais c'est les 2200 personnes qui
sont aujourd'hui en ingénierie sur les
territoires confiés par les NCT financée
par l'anct pour les appels à projets
tels que petites villes de demain ou
actions quaredevil aujourd'hui ils sont
en train de travailler de phosphorer de
de produire et il faudrait pas que
demain on abandonne les élus en pleine
campagne pour en leur disant mais il y a
pas de financement pour les projets
qu'on a mis en place alors il y aura
toujours la DETR la des cils et le fond
vert mais ça nécessiterait aussi une
réflexion sur sur
la norme déception que qu'il faudra
l'attention particulière qu'il faudra
avoir sur sur tous les projets qui ont
été mis en place par cette ingénierie et
produit par par cette ingénierie locale
vaste sujet pour répondre
je commence peut-être par la fin pour
répondre à toutes les interventions sur
pour revenir sur le sujet de
l'ingénierie vous avez complètement
raison on est aujourd'hui revenus un peu
au milieu du gué dans le sens où on a
décrit les effectifs de l'État depuis
des années et puis on a ces dernières
années remis avec les programmes qui ont
été initiés à la création de l'anct et
porter sur vraiment des programmes
territoriaux partant des projets des
élus on a mis des chefs de projets
co-financés par l'État permettant aux
élus de développer leurs projets et
après d'avoir avec des comités des
financeurs un certain nombre de projets
financés et une meilleure action
concertée de tous les financeurs sur un
territoire cette idée là effectivement
elle a très bien marché et d'ailleurs
moi je me permets un peu de m'inscrire
en fou sur ce qui a été dit sur action
coeur de ville dans le sens où mon
retour mon modeste niveau c'est que les
234 mères qui font partie du programme
en sont très contents alors évidemment
peut-être ceux qui sont pas dans le
programme mais ils ont il y a quand même
3 milliards d'euros engagés sur les 5
milliards qui étaient prévus sur la
période et qui continue à se dérouler
qui sont 3 milliards de crédits réels
évidemment les communes cofinances et
les intercouls leur projet mais c'est
sûr madame la sénatrice qu'il y a un
financement par les collectivités de
leur proposer mais avec 3 milliards des
partenaires de la banque des territoires
de Lana de la rue et de tous ceux et
bien sûr de la dstr dans tous ces
projets là donc c'est vrai que il y a
quand même beaucoup de moyens publics
qui ont été remis la difficulté c'est
qu'ils ont été remis sur certains
territoires aujourd'hui les bourses les
petites villes et avec un sujet sur les
maillage plus fin qui est posé
aujourd'hui sur vraiment la ruralité
comment accompagner ces territoires qui
sont pas dans ces programmes petite
ville action cœur de ville ou territoire
d'industrie donc une vraie question et
puis après une question un peu de est-ce
que il faut remettre des effectifs dans
les collectivités ou est-ce qu'on n'est
pas allé un peu loin dans cette voie au
détriment des services de l'État qui
eux-mêmes n'ont plus les moyens
d'accompagner et c'est vrai que c'est
cette question on se pose aujourd'hui de
savoir est-ce qu'il faut pas vraiment
maintenant remettre les effectifs dans
l'état et puis aussi l'autre question
fondamentale que vous avez et tous
évoqué c'est la coordination de
l'ingénierie sur les territoires parce
qu'en fait des fois on sait pas quels
sont les leviers il y a cette année un
enjeu qui est la renégociation des
conventions ancêtéréma addem qui est
donc des territoires et en rude
d'ailleurs tous les partenaires de
l'anct les conventions arrivent à
expiration doivent être négociées à la
fin de l'année ça ça va être un vrai
sujet pour être sûr d'avoir un vrai
travail en commun parce que la première
génération de convention à part avec le
serema il s'était très concret bon moi
je dis franchement pour les autres
opérateurs c'était pas des conventions
très opérationnelles là l'idée c'est
d'imbriquer et de bien se répartir les
rôles de le faire au niveau central et
au niveau local et puis de remettre
vraiment le sous-préfet au centre
effectivement comme acteur un peu le
guichet unique avec le comité local de
cohésion des territoires mais c'est vrai
que ça c'est une feuille de route
ambitieuse que le directeur général de
la NCT a dû aussi vous présenter et
qu'il faut lancer maintenant
effectivement pour vraiment améliorer
cette situation et favoriser la
lisibilité sur les
fonds l'articulation fond vert des
etoter des cils qui est effectivement
un sujet que vous avez vraiment abordé
alors déjà je vous dis d'où je parle moi
je suis responsable à la DGCL de la
déconcentration la répartition de la
déconcentration et le suivi de la DETR
et de la décile je ne m'occupe pas du
fond vert toutefois l'articulation entre
les trois fonds nous préoccupe beaucoup
et donc à ce titre je connais très bien
le fonctionnement du fond vert mais je
vous dis pourquoi pour que vous sachiez
qui qui gère quoi sur effectivement ces
trois ces trois fonds la question elle
est le fond vert et nouveau donc la
question est effectivement vraiment
posée de savoir comment bien les
articuler pour les années à venir et
notamment dans le cadre des débats de la
loi de finances qui vont venir c'est une
question qui se pose alors il y a une
question de montant globale de voilà
nous on défend le maintien des 4
milliards et évidemment voir une hausse
de ces de ces crédits évidemment dans
les débats interministériels mais
au-delà du montant global de soutien aux
collectivités la question c'est la
vocation de chacun de ces fonds et c'est
là que j'ai une petite nuance avec
Monsieur d'Arnaud sur la question
vraiment spécifique fond vert et autres
au fond que je effectivement peu
globalisé c'est que le fond vert il a 14
portes d'entrée extrêmement ambitieuses
de transition écologique et donc nous à
la DGCL et nous semble que il est
absolument pertinent de défendre l'idée
qu'il n'y a pas que la transition
écologique qui nécessite un soutien de
l'État en tout cas c'est la position que
l'on tient à nous dans les débats
interministériels sur cette question de
l'articulation et on ne voudrait pas
je sais que c'est pas du tout ça votre
idée mais on voudrait pas qu'une
enveloppe unique
puisse conduire à ce que on oublie que
il y a des d'autres projets
l'accessibilité des bâtiments publics la
tout ce qui est évidemment création
d'équipements sportifs il y a beaucoup
d'autres projets d'intérêt général
portés par les élus qui ne sont pas
classables aisément dans dans du un
objectif dans de verdissement même si
tous les projets aujourd'hui doivent
intégrer les meilleurs normes
environnementales et nous ce qu'on dit
c'est que les projets décident DETR ils
doivent faire être on doit accompagner
les élus à faire de l'éco-conception on
doit améliorer ces dotations pour
qu'elles soient et aussi de l'ingénierie
que comprennent en compte les surcoûts
écologiques de beaux projets qui soient
au meilleur normes environnementales
mais pour autant c'est pas forcément des
projets verts et donc il faut qu'on
puisse continuer à subventionner ces
projets là voilà de notre point de vue
et c'est pour ça que l'enveloppe unique
qui du coup risquerait d'être une
absorption c'est ça je sais que c'est
pas du tout ce que vous prenez je vais
vous
dire
ma frustration est à son paroxysme mais
je ne voudrais pas qu'on je ne voudrais
pas qu'on se méprenne sauf à ce que vous
me démontriez dans les quelques minutes
qui nous restent le contraire on est sur
trois dotations
qui sont restes restent
en matière d'attribution du pouvoir
discrétionnaire des préfets qu'ils
soient de région ou de départements nous
avons cru comprendre de la même du démat
de quelque chose qui ne relève pas du
secret que chaque préfet a une feuille
de route donc je ne vois pas comment par
quel malice ou par quel biais la volonté
de l'État
ne serait pas à un moment donné respecté
il suffirait pardon vous donner quelque
chose de très pratico pratique
permettez-moi d'être trivial mais il
suffirait que à l'instar de ce qui est
fait dans la DETR l'État central
réaffirme sa volonté de voir dans une
enveloppe globale chacun des items que
vous évoquiez y compris en matière
d'écologie être respectée mais on
simplifierait mais
pardon de vous le dire donc il y a
aucune malice dans notre propos et je
finirai juste par un mot c'est que
finalement on est dans le même bateau et
je pense qu'on aurait tort de penser
qu'on est là à jouer l'un contre l'autre
parce que n'ayez enfin je veux dire
aucun doute sur le fait que le maire
d'une commune de saint-sa habitants pour
lui tout ça procède finalement de l'état
du vote du budget au Parlement et donc
on est caution solidaire voilà donc je
pense qu'à un moment et on peut pas
faire sans vous parce que tout ça relève
comme nous avions eu l'occasion de
discuter avec la ministre lors de 3DS du
pouvoir réglementaire l'état donc je
veux dire il y a un moment donné enfin
voilà il y a pas ma liste dans nos
propos il y a pas une volonté de changer
brutalement ou radicalement simplement
de trouver de l'efficacité de
l'efficience je rajouterais juste que
pas expliquer un maire parce que
j'entends ce que vous dites que au nom
des débats mystériels et de ce qui peut
se passer à un moment donné à Bercy et
certains arbitrages il vaut mieux garder
trois fonds plutôt qu'un seul cercle en
fait si vous voulez jusque voilà non
mais la question de défendre etc j'en
peux l'entendre mais elle n'est pas
entendable en rêve par le voilà par le
client
c'est normal qui réalise mais je termine
mon propos sur le fait que je partage je
distingue la question des objectifs de
chacun des fonds et des objectifs des
politiques publiques qui sont poursuivis
derrière avec ces dotations qui me
semble devoir continuer à répondre à des
critères multiples et des circuits et
des circuits effectivement là on a une
énorme marge de progrès pour que ce soit
transparent pour l'élu et je suis
complètement vraiment plus que d'accord
sur le fait que les l'élu le fait qu'il
y ait trois enveloppes et d'ailleurs
vous l'avez tous dit et je et vous avez
raison les préfets ont fait un jeu de
bonneto cette année c'est tout à fait
logique entre des projets qui étaient
avant sur la dotr et de la des cils mais
qui était des projets verts puisque la
dother et la décile en financé
énormément notamment la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments étaient financés
par la décile et donc ils les ont
basculés sur le fond vert pour pouvoir
après financer d'autres projets qui
rentraient pas dans les critères du fond
vert sur la doter des cils et ils ont
effectivement fait ça et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que dans certains territoires
il y a des difficultés à avoir des
retour aujourd'hui des prélever parce
qu'ils sont en train de faire ce travail
et c'est vrai que pour l'élu ça devrait
être complètement transparent avec bien
sûr un formulaire unique et une
contrainte qui soit internalisée par
l'État
[Musique]
si vous avez
si vous avez d'autres précisions
monsieur
non si juste un dernier petit point mais
c'est alors là ça concerne plus le
travail
législatif mais dont on sait et dont on
a toujours eu à coeur de de le préparer
et de vous associer aussi en amont à ce
travail il me vient à l'esprit un sujet
qui se rappelle à nous au travers
différentes propositions de loi qui est
celui de la question de l'eau et de
l'assainissement
et je vais pas parler du fond du sujet
on en parle suffisamment ici même mais
de ce qui procède est-ce que ce qui
malheureusement fait qu'on en arrive à
relégiférer et et revenir sur la
question de la sub délégation pourquoi
je réinterroge ce sujet de la suite
délégation parce qu'à la limite il n'a
pas vocation demain qu'à ce borner au
seul question de l'eau et de
l'assainissement et pour moi ça reste un
sujet sur lequel malheureusement on n'a
pas été au fond des choses et on
suffisamment vu notamment avec votre
prédécesseur pour essayer de revisiter
le sujet et de le rendre plus efficient
notamment lorsque alors je
reviens sur le sujet de l'eau on a mis
en place le la possibilité pour les
communes de reprendre l'exercice de la
compétence mais sans penser
au circulaire qui traitait de la
question financière du vote du budget
éventuellement de l'articulation une
commune intercommunalité pourquoi je
prends cet exemple là c'est que tous les
sujets qui concernent et pour encore une
fois revenir aux auditions que nous
avons eu aux entretiens aux visites que
nous avons fait sur le territoire les
lui il a parfois trop le sentiment
qu'on pense la loi qu'on fabrique la loi
mais qu'il n'y a pas de service après
vote en réalité et que l'application
l'absence de décret
le dévoiement finalement de l'esprit de
la loi et du législateur
conjugué parfois
à des interprétations et encore une fois
qu'il n'y ait pas méprise dans mes
propos je ne vise aucun préfet aucun
responsable de l'état mais des fois
l'interprétation qu'on peut faire en
fonction de situation qui sont très
différentes et donc qui rendent
l'exercice plus compliqué mais on a
aussi la difficulté à expliquer ça au
maire aux élus qu'on rencontre parce que
eux nous font remonter des sujets on
essaie de leur donner une suite et une
traduction législative et donc
d'apporter une réponse et une solution
et malheureusement même quand on a voté
et on a trouvé des architecture quand on
a trouvé des réponses législatives on se
rend compte de la difficulté
d'appliquer les textes ou parfois
malheureusement d'assister un peu un
dévoiement et donc comment la directrice
générale des collectivités locales
imagine la possibilité d'avoir un
contrôle alors en dehors de celui du
Parlement et singulièrement du Sénat
pour que justement on est peut-être une
lecture alors là c'est je
vous rends pour le coup hommage c'est
qu'à chaque fois qu'on vous sollicite
pour essayer comme on l'a fait sur la
sur la circulaire vous avez une
réactivité sur sur ces sujets sur la
question de la sub délégation mais
comment on peut peut-être
permettre d'avoir une meilleure
application des textes et surtout un
regard parfois de le dire j'aime pas ce
terme parce que il recouvre beaucoup de
gens mais un peu plus de bon sens et de
pragmatisme qui correspond à l'état
d'esprit des élus sur les territoires
en fait effectivement le l'enjeu c'est
que des sujets d'application nous
remontent avec des cas concrets et il
est vrai que nous très coquine
quotidiennement on est saisi par les
préfets de difficultés d'interprétation
des textes qu'on regarde concrètement
avec eux et avec les élus souvent
directement quel est le projet et
apporter et on donne l'interprétation
qui est la plus facilite entre
nous semble que c'est complètement notre
mission or dans le respect du droit mais
quand la volonté du législateur était
claire quand un projet en dépend on
donne systématiquement l'interprétation
la plus facilitante la difficulté c'est
qu'après tous les projets ne nous toutes
les questions ne nous remontent pas donc
c'est vrai que les préfets sont au
courant qui peuvent saisir les
administrations centrales pour avoir des
lectures des textes qui quand il y a des
éléments bloquants on donne aussi des
instructions qui nous permettent souvent
d'apporter quand même de la souplesse et
notamment beaucoup de pragmatisme dans
les mises en oeuvre financières parce
que c'est souvent là qu'il y a des
difficultés ou que les des défis sont
pas toujours armés pour ce qu'on est
dispos qui sont nouveaux et plus
spécifiquement sur le sujet de la sub
délégation c'est vrai qu'il y a eu
beaucoup de questions au début
aujourd'hui là aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
retour sur combien de sub délégation ont
été réalisés alors en fait sur la
question de l'eau c'est assez logique
qu'on est peu de retour parce qu'a
priori elle avait vocation plus à
s'appliquer à partir du janvier 2026 et
donc c'est là que les sup délégation si
la loi est telle qu'elle est entre en
vigueur et donc il y a un enjeu en tout
cas de vraiment
accompagner dès maintenant pour que le
système soit le plus facile possible
et donc voilà moi je vous redis mais
vous le savez mais mon ouverture totale
a travaillé sur ces sujets avec vous et
surtout sujet que vous identifiez où on
peut avoir une interprétation qui
facilite ou qu'on peut donner et faire
des foires aux questions des circulaires
des consignes au préfet pour pour
appliquer les choses de manière la plus
souple possible
merci beaucoup pour votre disponibilité
et pour pour vous exercer ce
et puis chers collègues question
gouvernement maintenant merci madame la
Présidente merci beaucoup à vous madame
monsieur